so when we're thinking about the ideas
for this talk we were kind of looking at
customers who are trying to isolate
things within within that cluster and so
typical scenario is you have some sort
of trusted workload some sort of
untrusted workload the examples we use
on the talk our payment system is the
trusted side and a company that is doing
sort of web hosting has a container
that's provided by a customer and that
that's basically untrusted code from a
security perspective and so people want
to like to separate these things out so
you could use a cluster boundary but a
lot of people are actually looking at
kind of putting the the trusted thing on
trusted nodes and the untrusted thing on
untrusted nodes so using a VM and a node
effectively to separate those those two
kinds of workloads and that is a pretty
comfortable place for security people
they are used to separating things with
VMs but in Kupa days it's actually a
little bit different there's actually
quite a lot of connections between nodes
and a lot of privilege that's held by
nodes that makes that isolation just
probably not as good as a lot of people
think it is and so we really wanted to
highlight that in this talk and give a
practical demonstration of kind of how
to break that isolation and sort of talk
about some alternatives
you wanna talk about kind of like node
versus pod and what the alternatives are
there yeah sure
so the node is really complicated
there's a lot of stuff going on and the
attacker an attacker who has compromised
a node has access to the union of all of
those different things that the node is
using they have a pretty large toolkit
even if you're running least privileged
and so we kind of compare what the
attacker has access to in the node with
what they have access to in the pod
which it you can scope down much more
and this slide kind of summarizes the
differences there and then we wrap up by
looking at what you can actually do to
defend in addition to or instead of node
isolation before the attacker can get to
actually leveraging all of those
privileges at the node level they first
have to go through your application
getting remote code execution they then
need to break out of the container and
only then can they get access to the
whole node so first we recommend
hardening the application then we look
at different ways of pardoning the
container and we talked about sandboxes
like gke sandboxes and deep with divisor
as a way of hardening that pod boundary
a lot more and then we see that at that
point node isolation isn't as critical
so we finish off by talking about how
nodes are really complicated and
shouldn't be your only measure of
defense and instead we recommend using
container isolation and pod sandboxing
as a much more secure form of isolation
so I hope you enjoyed the talk and we'll
be hanging out the Google booth so
please come by and talk to us if you
wanna talk about it
charity and GA and isolation or anything
else Thanks
[Music]